les chadoc sont sur la planète à haut
ils croit que la terre est en
dessous ils avaient installé un système
compliqué de tuyau pour pomper l'eau de
la planète et la mettre à
sec
[Musique]
les poissons volants au début trouvaient
ça amusant et venait les regarder
travailler l'eau d'un côté commençait à
baisser et de l'autre il y avait une
petite planète qui se
formait il pompèrent comme ça pendant
assez longtemps mais pas le plus petit
bout de terre
n'apparaissait si bien qu'à la fin il
pompèrent tout il s'aperçur enfin qu'il
s'était trompé et qu'il n'y avait pas de
terre du tout il ne restait que les
poissons volant qui était pour ainsi
dire obligé de nager à pied sec et qui
n'était pas content du tout ils allaient
voir les
chadoc et en mangèrent un certain nombre
puis ils exigèrent qu'ils remettent leur
planète là où il l'avaient prise et plus
vite que
ça et les chadoc encore une fois se
remirent à
pomper